hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear my movie review show so it's
february and if you saw my last movie
review which i think was irreversible i
said that for the month of february i
was going to actually do a theme i might
not do that every month because it seems
like kind of a pain in the ass but to be
honest i have such a huge backlog of
movies that i want to
watch or re-watch and review that
sometimes it's easier for me to
kind of have a theme for the month so at
least i know like which ones to watch
and which ones to pick
and because and i've brought this up on
a bunch of my previous shows uh shutter
just added a documentary about folk
horror which is really really good
and uh watching that kind of got me
you know interested in a lot of movies
on there that i hadn't seen before so i
decided for february i was going to do
some folk horror movies new ones and old
ones now this movie here i don't know if
it's the first thing you'd think of when
you think folk horror although it does
have a lot of folklore elements in it
now i actually saw this movie back in
2017 or 2000 or early 2018 and i loved
it and i uh wrote about it on my blog
and ever since then i've been thinking
about it thinking oh man i really need
to like you know re-watch that and uh
review it for the show because it's one
that's really pretty much universally
acclaimed and loved uh so
i figured you know since it is it does
have folk horror elements i decided that
this would be a good time to do it and
the movie that i'm talking about is the
whaling from 2016.
now this was the third film directed by
na hong jin i have not seen his other
two which i think are called the chaser
and the yellow c i believe uh this is
south korean film the south korean title
is uh goksyong which i think is also the
name of the village uh where the movie
takes place
this movie
it's crazy i mean south korean cinema
south korean horror cinema south korean
action cinema i mean we just talked
about i saw the devil not too long ago
which not exactly a horror movie but it
does have a lot of horror movie elements
to it and i think i mean south korean
horror and revenge cinema are really
kind of operating on a different level
and i mean that in the most
complementary way possible because
honestly some of the more recent films
i'm talking maybe like last 10 15 years
out of south korea that i've seen i mean
they've all been [ __ ] dynamite i mean
just
just amazing amazing films and i'm
talking you know about the whaling the
host trained to boost on i mean there's
just so many [ __ ] good ones you know
i saw the devil and i'm not entirely i
guess it's because i don't know they're
just willing to take and this movie in
particular
is really willing to play with
genre and tone
and is willing to kind of like take its
time and not do what you would expect
this is a very
ballsy movie in the sense that i really
can't see an american filmmaker
attempting this
and if they did attempt it it might not
go too well because this movie
i'm not even entirely sure what genre i
would call it it's almost kind of like
it starts out
as like almost like a police procedural
but with
horror comedy elements and i know that
sounds bizarre but actually the first
part of it is actually kind of funny uh
but there's also like grim [ __ ] going on
too but it's
not exactly played for laughs but there
is kind of a lot of comedy in there
and then as the movie goes on it kind of
turns into like a mystery and then
there's kind of all this other like way
hardcore like supernatural horror
elements to it later on it's almost kind
of like and this might be sort of like a
glib thing to say but it almost seems
like if you guys have seen the other
korean movie which is [ __ ] great
memories of murder it's kind of like
that but with the exorcist kind of and
then like a folk horror kind of thing
and then like some funny [ __ ] in it it's
just it's kind of all over the place but
i don't mean that in a bad way honestly
the first time i saw this movie a couple
years back i'm like holy crap nobody
it's like no western filmmaker i don't
think this is probably you know this is
generalization i'm sure somebody might
but i'm just saying you wouldn't see a
western filmmaker
making a movie like this and have it
succeed in
i mean just in spades it's really really
great now i can understand why
this movie is pretty much universally
adored i have seen a couple people that
didn't
really care for it but
not that many i mean most people and if
you actually really sort of let yourself
get immersed in this film because you
really kind of do have to it almost has
this very strange incantation sort of
power to it
and
you know which is a good thing it really
just kind of like sucks you in and just
kind of like takes you on this journey
and you're never really entirely sure
where it's going and like a lot of south
korean horror cinema and revenge cinema
it has a lot of emotion at its core a
lot of emotional tragedy family tragedy
things like that so it really does get
you invested in its characters and
sympathizing with its characters you
really um you know you really get
emotionally invested in
the bad things that are happening to
them
but
it's just um i will say that
this movie as i said you need to immerse
yourself in it and
know going in that it's very long it's
about two hours and 40 minutes i want to
say thereabouts um so it is a time
commitment and it's very long for what
is ostensibly a horror film
but
if you just kind of
go with it and you know just watch it
and just sort of let it
do its magic on you then um there is
really a lot to uh to enjoy and a lot to
recommend in it this is also a movie
that i think i don't think it
necessarily needs two viewings but i
think um it definitely i mean because i
caught a lot more the second time that i
watched it because there's a lot of
symbolism in there particularly a lot of
kind of like religious symbolism not
necessarily just having to do with kind
of uh folk beliefs in you know this
little village in korea but also having
to do with biblical uh you know kind of
stuff biblical illusions and i kind of
feel like
you really need to kind of like see it a
couple times to pick up on everything
that's going on in there because the
story in this
is very
complex and you really kind of have to
do be you know you really do have to pay
attention to kind of what's going on and
all the conversations and
stuff like that because there's a lot of
moving parts but
i mean i do think it's really a very
very rewarding uh film if you are
willing to
you know go to it you know what i'm
saying
so what we have in this film which as i
said i mean one it looks [ __ ]
beautiful the cinematography is
beautiful of this like little village
and these like
mountains and everything about it is
just
it the whole thing has like just an
atmosphere of dread to it now i think
i've read that this took actually six
months to shoot and mostly because
because they wanted a natural light
pretty much for everything natural light
natural weather so whenever they had a
scene that called for for example
you know like a really bad uh you know
lightning storm a rainstorm then they
would actually wait
uh for that to happen you know what i
mean so instead of like just spraying
the actors with uh with a hose or
whatever they actually wanted everything
to be like as
you know all the weather and the
lighting and stuff like that to be as
natural as possible so sometimes they
just kind of had to take stuff stuff as
they could do it and
the attention to detail the attention to
the craft of filmmaking is really really
evident uh in the whole thing and it
just has this this kind of spiraling
it's kind of going down because as i
said it starts out almost kind of like
funny almost kind of like going into i
i don't know if i'd call to be getting a
straight up comedy but it definitely is
kind of like has a lot of dark comedy
elements at the beginning and it does
even have some parts that are almost
kind of like goofy
but then as it goes on it just starts
getting more and more grim and like
darker and darker and darker until at
the end it is like absolutely not funny
at all and it's just like it's just
horrific so i mean the fact that he was
able to pull that off and that it's this
just this cohesive movie is just kind of
amazing
so what you have at the beginning
is there is a a police officer named
jongu and he's like the main character
now john goo
he's kind of he's a sympathetic
character but he's not real sympathetic
at the beginning because he seems like
kind of he's kind of chubby he's kind of
lazy
um he's kind of he's a cop but when he
gets called to scenes he's very uh
cowardly like he doesn't want to deal
with it he seems very very out of his
depth and he kind of seems a little bit
like an idiot
so that's where kind of a lot of the
humor stems from is that it's obvious
that the cops in this little bitty town
um when really bad [ __ ] starts happening
in the town they are absolutely not
equipped to deal with it because they're
kind of morons or they're just kind of
like not used to this or they don't just
don't want to deal with it
so he's so that's his character now he's
got a wife uh and a mother-in-law and a
little bitty daughter named hyojin uh
who you know becomes a large focus of
the plot later on and actually there is
a really nice kind of burgeoning
relationship or not burgeoning but you
know what i mean there's a really good
kind of sweet uh relationship between
father and son even though her father
and daughter rather even though um he's
not a bad father he's just kind of like
a schlub you know what i mean he's just
kind of like a schlubby clueless
type of dude uh who's just kind of like
going through the motions and not
getting all too involved in things he's
not super ambitious he's not super smart
he's not you know he's just living in
this small town with his family and just
kind of shuffling around living his life
and not really like appreciating much of
anything but he's not a bad guy at heart
so uh very near the beginning of the
movie uh he gets called to this scene
which
uh you can tell that none of the cops in
this town have ever seen anything like
this before they all know this guy he's
a local ginseng farmer
and it appears that this guy has pretty
much slaughtered his whole entire family
now the guy that did it
is just sitting on the porch of the
house and he looks like
a zombie essentially he's all covered
with these [ __ ] boils his eyes are
all whited over he's all like spaced out
they can't get any information out of
him and he has just slaughtered like his
whole entire family it's just gore
everywhere
so uh the cops are obviously uh
flabbergasted and have no idea what to
make of all this
and uh you know it's kind of like the
cops are sort of like well maybe it's
you know maybe that he ate some bad
mushrooms or something and it made him
like
you know trip the [ __ ] out
and
you know some of they say that they kind
of print that in the media like to sort
of you know get the media off their back
or whatever but some of the cops are
like no i don't think so and then uh you
know this stuff starts to circulate
about this stranger who moved into the
village not too long prior he's a
fisherman and he's japanese now they
never do say what his name is this is
the everybody in the movie just calls
him the [ __ ] um so you never do find out
what the dude's name is
and uh so he's this fisherman he's you
know he's a stranger
and
you know there's kind of like uh
still
some tension i guess between the koreans
and the japanese so like xenophobia kind
of like adds into it too and all these
people kind of like tell those cops all
these different stories about this
japanese man uh where they're just kind
of like oh he raped a woman down by the
river um this one guy who was like a
hunter he had he would had like caught a
deer and he fell and he hit his head and
then when he woke up he saw what he
thought was this japanese man
like naked except for this diaper
loincloth situation and he was eating
the raw deer like he was just eating its
guts out and then when he turned toward
him his eyes were like bright red
so uh so a lot of rumors have started to
circulate about this japanese man and
everybody thinks that maybe he's kind of
like behind
this weird [ __ ] that's been going on
because
it's not just this ginseng farmer at the
beginning who you know gets killed or
you know is all covered with boils or
whatever then it seems like it starts to
spread throughout the village they start
seeing other people they get these kind
of boils and then their eyes go all
crazy and then they start flipping out
and you know killing their whole entire
families so as the story goes on they
start to suspect that yeah maybe this
japanese man does have something to do
with it john goo is sort of interested
in the case but he's not personally
involved in it so he's just kind of you
know it's like they call him to a scene
it's like he shows up late and he's just
like oh you know my mother-in-law was
sick or i was sleeping or whatever you
know what i mean he's just kind of one
of those type of
schlubby dude you know what i mean
but uh as as the story goes on he
actually becomes more personally
involved because his daughter hyo-jin
appears to
be succumbing to whatever this thing is
that's spreading throughout the village
now at first you're not entirely sure
what it is at first it's kind of like
it seems like a disease because like
people it seems like it's spreading and
like i said they people start getting
these symptoms like boy like bubonic
plague or something they get like boils
all over their face or all over their
side or whatever and then eventually
they flip out
and kill their whole family or kill
themselves uh in really horrible ways so
at first as i said they're kind of
thinking it's a disease but as the time
goes on and as hyojin the little girl
becomes starts becoming affected so at
this point jon goo and his uh wife and
mother-in-law start to suspect that
maybe
this is uh something supernatural going
on because their daughter is starting to
act
really really weird like she's
uh she's eating all this food like just
stuffing food in her face not food that
she normally wouldn't eat like fish
she's starting to swear at her dad and
she's kind of starting to
develop some boils on her side uh jon
goo is also having nightmares about uh
ostensibly this japanese man with the
you know with the loincloth and the red
eyes and everything so you know the
mother-in-law is kind of like we need to
get a shaman in here so she asks one of
the neighbors to recommend one
she's like because i'm pretty sure this
is a demon and so everybody starts to
think that the japanese man is somehow
behind
this demon or whatever is taken over the
village now one thing that uh obviously
leads to them thinking this too or at
least leads to them thinking that the
japanese man is behind these things
is uh two of the cops jongu and his
partner they get this guy his partner's
nephew i think it is is like a deacon
and he speaks some japanese so they take
him with uh to translate
and they go to the japanese man's house
like his little shack or whatever and
while they're looking around they
totally illegally like break in the
deacon's like this is illegal like you
guys shouldn't be doing and they're just
like [ __ ] it you know it's like because
at this point like i said they're
convinced that this dude is up to
something and there's like they're going
extra legal you know what i mean so they
bust into the guy's house and they find
this like little room in the back of his
house that has
all of the all of these pictures
of
like a [ __ ] ton of people there's
there's pictures of them alive and then
pictures of them dead and there's
pictures of them like from the crime
scenes and stuff and some of the people
you recognize from you know earlier you
know people that got killed in the
village and there's also a bunch of
stuff that seems to like belong to some
of the
some of the victims and this is when jon
goo gets really involved because he
finds in this dude's cabin he finds a
little shoe like a little sneaker
belonging to his daughter like it has
her name in it and everything so he
starts to become convinced yeah this guy
is you know put a spell on hers
possessing her or something like that
so they bring in the shaman and the
shaman is basically like yeah the
japanese man is a ghost
and he's just going around wreaking
havoc he's essentially like a demon
right and so he's just going around and
um you know jungkook is like why would
he pick on my daughter like of all
people he didn't ask about because like
i said he didn't he didn't really get
emotionally invested in this until
obviously his daughter was affected like
pr when prior to this like all the other
villagers he was just kind of like oh
that's [ __ ] up you know what i mean
but uh he's like well why why would this
guy like pick on my daughter and
i mean the shaman says actually makes
kind of an interesting analogy he says
well you know he he's a demon he's just
like a fisherman it's like you know when
you go fishing you don't know what fish
you're gonna catch you're just putting
bait out there and whoever
takes it and she's like you know so he
would just had some bait out there and
your daughter just happened to take it
so it was just like a random occurrence
uh you know which is kind of like freaky
so as it goes on i really don't want to
spoil this because there's so many like
twists and turns in this and i think
it's better if you don't really know
where it's going exactly
but i will say that
there's okay so there's these really
long sequences of like the shaman doing
a ritual that is ostensibly supposed to
be getting the demon out of the little
girl
uh you also see the japanese man doing
his own
invocations or whatever for his own
nefarious purpose and i will note too
that there's another character in here
lurking around a woman in white whose
name is uh mum young which i think means
no name and uh she is kind of lurking
around too like and she's saying that
the japanese man is a demon
and all this other stuff
so
the three of these kind of magical uh
people
are sort of going around and it comes to
a thing where the story gets more and
more complex and you're not entirely
sure
until pretty much the very end
which
of these people you can trust and which
one you can't like you don't really know
who is the good guy or the bad guy
because they're telling
you know they're telling jongu who is
just this clueless you know backwater
small town policeman who has been thrust
into
essentially like a fight between the
grander forces of good and evil and he
has no [ __ ] idea what the hell is
going on
and all he wants to do is save his
daughter and that's all he's trying to
do
and he's completely out of his depth and
that i think that's what's so tragic
about this is that as i said he's just
like a normal working joe
who you know it was just thrust into the
situation it's just but force is much
larger than him and he doesn't really
have any sense of
you know
who is the good guy who is the bad guy
because everybody you know whether it's
the japanese man whether it's the woman
in white whether it's uh you know the
shaman
they're all telling him something
different and he's you know as far as
like supernatural who's the demon you
know what do you need to do in this
situation what's a protection what's a
curse all this other stuff and he
doesn't really have any
you know context for that he doesn't
really he didn't believe in any of that
so he's just really
kind of he doesn't really have any
defense against it because he doesn't
know who's telling him the truth and you
know he kind of gets
manipulated uh you know and it i think
that's what's kind of so sad about this
is that he really
doesn't have a chance to be honest
because he just doesn't really have any
idea what the hell is going on and as i
said these are forces much larger much
older than he's ever had to deal with
and there's just no way that he can beat
them really because he doesn't really
know what's going on
one review of this i saw that was
actually made a very astute observation
i think it was ryan hollinger actually
uh who's great if you haven't he's irish
dude
and he does kind of in-depth video
essays about various movies and he did
one on this
and uh his interpretation of it and he's
not the only person i've seen other
people interpret it this way too there
are a couple different ways you could
interpret it although i thought it was
pretty straightforward like at least
toward the end if you're kind of paying
attention
but like who the demon is and who's not
like who's good and who's bad
but he was pointing out that a lot of
the uh symbolism a lot of the kind of
stuff that's going on and it had to do
with
faith
uh and with maybe like the seven deadly
sins uh he's arguing he was arguing that
um john goo even though
he's you know as i said a good guy at
heart
he had committed these sins and it was
essentially him that was being punished
uh even though it was all these other
people around him that were suffering
and i actually really did like that
interpretation like watching it again i
mean there's definitely a lot of
christian like religious symbolism in
this it even starts with a bible quote
and there's a lot of stuff about you
know the devil and as i said it's it's a
lot about faith there's stuff about you
know there's one scene like toward the
very end where the woman in white
makes a thing about the [ __ ] crowing
three times which again kind of like a
biblical reference so it has a lot of
that in it so even though it has like a
lot of kind of traditional korean uh you
know folk magic type of stuff going into
like sympathetic magic it also has a lot
of stuff about christianity and about
you know a lot of biblical uh illusions
and stuff like that too which is really
cool but as i said this is a
wild
very very korean
stew of a movie that just has so many
elements and so many different things
going on in it
that
you would think that it would just be
this big confused mess and that it
totally wouldn't work but it completely
and totally does and it's almost kind of
like
miraculous i'm not really sure how how
it happened but this is an amazing
amazing film and like i said it's very
long so if you don't have the time
commitment to like sit down and actually
like immerse yourself in it wait until
you have time to do that because you
really do need to
pay attention to the conversations pay
attention to the symbolism and
just pay attention to all the little
nuances and you know everything that's
going on because it's a much richer
experience if you do that but i mean
it's just such a great great movie and
you know as i said pretty much every
south korean horror and revenge film
i've seen in the past 10 15 years has
been amazing i don't know if that's just
because we're getting the best ones like
over here but
i mean i don't think i've seen a bad one
so i i don't know what they're doing
over there but man they're [ __ ]
kicking our asses in a lot of ways i
don't want to say that because there
have been a lot of good uh you know
american and european ones lately too
but for some reason there's just
something about south korean ones that
they just they just get away with a lot
of stuff that i don't think you would
see a western filmmaker even attempting
and i kind of feel like the same thing
happened with something like parasite
which even though that kind of gets
slotted into being a horror movie too
that almost that had a lot of the same
kind of like dark comedy
satire kind of stuff to it too but then
it had all these other elements going on
like mystery thriller and the south
koreans filmmakers really seem to be
very very adept at combining genres in a
way that doesn't feel like tonal
whiplash uh so it makes their stories
like much richer and much more
unpredictable because you never really
know like what direction it's gonna go
in uh and this one in particular the
whaling i mean it's just it's almost
kind of like
it's almost like a long invocation of
its own you know what i mean so you
really do have to like spend time with
it and just let yourself go along with
it but
let me know if you guys have seen it and
what you thought about it i saw it on
netflix uh back in like i said 2000 it
was either late 2017 or early 2018. it's
not on netflix anymore at least in the
united states however if you have amazon
prime you can watch it on amazon prime
for free or i believe it's also on 2b
for free although it will have
commercials uh but you know if you don't
have amazon prime and want to you know
not want to pay to watch it then you can
uh by all means watch it on 2b i'm not
sure if 2b works in other countries like
somebody let me know but yeah if you've
seen the whaling let me know what you
thought about it in the comments and
that will do it for this flickers of
fear my february folk horror uh kind of
thing that i'm doing here and i will see
you guys on the next one bye